I want to jump to the story from the
Daily Mail we're talking about anarcho
tyranny we're talking about the the
justice system no longer uh bringing
Justice innocent people being locked up
and the Machine being weaponized against
uh it's the Democrats weaponizing the
system against political opponents but
here's what I think could actually lead
to an actual Revolution or Civil War
Moody's Cuts credit ratings of 10 U.S
banks and warns six more could face a
similar fate but firm insists U.S
banking system is not broken
this is uh disconcerting considering
what happened with Silicon Valley Bank
and several other Banks preview earlier
this year but we also have this from
timcast.com U.S credit card debt hits
record one trillion dollars total U.S
household debt top 17 trillion As
Americans turn to debt to cover living
expenses
do you know what the one thing there's a
few things that precipitate civil war
and revolution
you know the simplest is the most
obvious and simplest Catalyst for
governmental breakdown inflation would
be my no food oh run out of food yeah
when people are unable to buy food we
saw it in the Arab Spring you see it in
the French Revolution it's not absolute
but typically when people struggle to
make ends meet they become angry and
desperate and when they're hungry
nothing else matters so right now maybe
it's a little preliminary we're seeing
we're seeing corporate and governmental
collapse we're seeing our institutions
Decay we're saying the judicial system
Decay we're seeing the Democrats
weaponize government against their
political Rivals I will say this with
absolute certainty that Democrats are
cheating in the 2024 election
and what I mean by that is not that
there's fraud or they're doing any weird
about stuff what they're doing is fairly
obvious they're literally arresting and
criminally charging their political
opponents
a fair and honest election is when three
times they've done it three times that's
right or next week a fair and honest
election is when you say choose me I'm
the best don't choose him he's bad and
the other ass says the same thing then
people will decide that's a fair amount
of selection what they're doing now is
saying we can't win so lock him up and
prevent him and hobble him in any way
possible that's cheating yeah when you
when you take all that into
consideration with the fact that our
financial system is whacked out of
proportion If there really is a
substantial risk with everything going
on and there have been food shortages
especially with Cove and everything that
if the monetary system faces severe
turmoil people can't find houses to live
in people can't afford to pay rent
people can't afford to buy food you add
that into the mix with all the political
turmoil and
then something kicks off yeah I mean not
only that but also there's the concern
about inflation and stuff like that
because right now the the dollar is only
backed by confidence in in the
government and stuff so we really do
have a
a historic historically volatile
situation on our hands we've got re like
what is it like uh generation a couple
Generations or multiple Generations
since we've had economic inequality uh
oh of this yeah at this level and that's
something whether or not it I mean I
know that people's material like
material poverty is has gone down but if
you've got a society where there's
significant difference between the
highest earners and the lowest earners
and stuff you do get civil unrest and
you get unhappy populations you've got
you've got the changing of the the
global order when it comes to monetary
policy with bricks and with other you
know people starting to move away from
the dollar it's it's I don't see a whole
lot of like positive things on the
horizon let me let me double down on
that real briefly sick thanks man yeah
the the Federal Reserve had held the the
federal funds rate at a quarter point
for approximately a decade since the the
Great Recession they're just like we're
just gonna keep it at zero the zero
bound forever there'll be no problems
from that right and then then we're
going to print five trillion dollars in
the year 2020 and we're going to lock
down the economy create supply chain
shortages which also add to the
inflationary pressure and then in a
12-month period starting in February of
2002 they're going to start to hike the
FED funds rate very aggressively a half
point every time they have a meeting and
they're going to take it from a quarter
point up to approximately five and a
half six which then takes the mortgage
rates from three and a quarter and it
puts it up to seven and a half eight it
also makes it so that all of these T
bills and these uh short-term debt
instruments that are held on all of
these banking institutions they are now
bleeding all over the floor that's the
whole reason that Moody's is marking
them down by the way it is strictly a
Federal Reserve created crisis I want to
be very clear about that this would not
be happening the American people would
not be living off of credit cards and
have a trillion dollars of debt if it
weren't for inflation that's why all of
this has happened and let me add to that
uh it's this is all politics
you know I'm surprised this doesn't
happen sooner because an honest
evaluation of the way our banks are
regulated the decider about whether a
bank is solvent is a political appointee
in the Biden Administration and so all
these decisions are political uh the the
big the what is it the Silicon Valley
Bank that decision to shut that bank
down was a political decision made as a
result of lobbying by democrats yes and
then the bank here on the East Coast
that was subsequently shut down
signature the signature that bank was
perfectly fine uh but they didn't like
the fact that they were in the business
of crypto and they told them that and
that's the reason they were shut down we
knew from the 2008 uh shutdowns because
we got the documents Judicial Watch did
they didn't know why they were shutting
the banks down they just didn't have a
systematic way of of shutting Banks down
or or Doling out financial support for
the banks it was well we want everyone
to get the support so no one knows who
the banks are so the good Banks should
get money and the bad Banks should get
money and we'll disguise who the bad
banks are by making everyone else take
the subsidy it was completely political
the same goes with the Fitch knocking
down our uh credit rating here in the
United States
it's politics yep it's politics we've
got politicians who have decided that
printing money is and politicians of
both parties the best way to stay in
power is to print money and they don't
care what the consequences
yeah that's that's right transferring
wealth check out every pot you know and
um
so on top of the increase in as they
were increasing interest rates they kept
the spigot flowing in terms of spending
at the at the government level and you
know there's no sign that it's going to
be curtailed no it's not going to be
curtailed you know so now we're all
supposed to be excited they've increased
you know they've cut down our salaries
by four or five percent practically
speaking or spending power over the last
year
and now we're supposed to be satisfied
that we've lost that purchasing power
that they've been cemented the the
prices have been cemented at a higher
level they're not getting lower they're
just not getting high as high as quickly
as they previously did so you know
there's no easy way out for this but
there is you know other than curtailing
government spending taking politics out
of the regulation of the banking
industry meaning the government's got to
get you know spend a little less money
trying to effectively uh tell everyone
that we will ensure all deposits as
opposed to making sure that banks that
make bad decisions go away the dodo bird
I keep thinking that maybe we could
default on the debt to the Federal
Reserve or at least the interest to the
Federal Reserve and be like yo suck it
but that's like telling the Swiss bank
the bank for international settlements
suck it and when then they would they
then excommunicate the United States
from the liberal economic order if we
did something probably it doesn't it's
not that hard you just need the change
the trajectory just a little bit for
small government people it's discipline
warning because we can spend a whole lot
of money if we just change not too much
as far as you know conservatives would
be but in terms of like Social Security
and government spending just change the
directory just a little bit and it's say
and and it allows the government to
spend money virtually World Without End
forever uh but they don't even want to
do that well what's so frustrating is
like literally a 10 cut across the board
and we could balance the budget pretty
quickly because they've taken so much in
tax receipts and it's like do you think
that there's not 10 in excess spending
in every federal department like yeah
I'm sure there is just look at the war
in Ukraine look at where all those
billions are going like you think they
can't cut 50 of that and still get the
same bang for their Buck it's just an
absurdity but I I want to like really
emphasize to the conservative audience
is listening right now it's income it's
incumbent upon you guys to understand
that it is Federal Reserve policy that
is making it so challenging to have
household formation to get married to
have kids all of these things that you
guys consistently lament you miss the
biggest factor is that in inflation has
forced both parents into the workforce
and it has made it incredibly and
increasingly challenging to be a parent
to get married to buy a home all of
these things are Federal Reserve policy
uh you know okay but that's only the
government can do this time that's a
large component of it but cultural
issues of course very important too it's
hand in hand I think cultural is the
bigger the central banks they're all
kind of controlling and manipulating the
media which is manipulating the culture
to because why are people not more up in
arms about the Federal Reserve if they
knew if you knew that that private bank
was disrupting your life you would have
taken it back 800 years ago I would hope
if we did not ever have the revolution
in the workplace women stayed at home it
wouldn't matter what the Federal Reserve
tried to do women would not but but that
coincides with the Inception of the
Federal Reserve 1913 you have the
women's Liberation they start to hit the
workforce I think it's all part and
parcel of the same Dynamic I'm sure but
I mean the cultural change has to happen
first maybe I think I think they I think
one chases the other it's like it's not
necessarily a World War One got people
really really culturally messed up right
after the Federal Reserve was ready to
go yeah like that you've got no nothing
politicians sitting at the knobs trying
to manage the economy that yet they
don't know what they're doing and things
get out of whack now and again because
they don't know what they're doing I
mean I remember in 2008 I read in the
Wall Street Journal when they first
started giving money to the way to the
banks the bank said to the Wall Street
Journal well they didn't give us a
choice I said well isn't that
interesting so we Sue Judicial Watch
suit for the records long story short
they said we got the records we want to
meet with the top nine Banks bring them
into the treasury Department
and the chief of staff is like okay who
are the top nine Banks so they didn't
even know who the top mine Banks were so
they bring him in the heads of the top
banks of the United States of America
and they said to them we're gonna take
we're going to give you subsidy and you
should know that if you don't want to
take it we're going to make it so that
your Regulators require you to do so and
they made them sign little permission
forms two or three lines I agree I Jamie
Diamond agreed to take 12 billion
dollars whatever you know contingent on
approval from the board of directors
that's how they quote bailed out the
banks and it was never a bailout it's a
takeover yeah if you every time you hear
about bailing out Banks substitutes a
word takeover and you understand why
we're in the state we are you can watch
the big The Big Short is a movie that uh
is really good that covers this kind of
stuff and also too big to fail was
another one too big to fail was kind of
the crisis from the government's
perspective and The Big Short was like
three or four different groups of people
that actually kind of saw the housing
crisis come and what it was what it
would do to the to the the whole economy
um
actually you know better than I do you
would go well yeah I mean I was a
mortgage lender so I I and I came out of
college right into the teeth of that and
it was a nightmare
um and fortunately you know we've gotten
past that but there was actually a
bailout with silicon and uh and the
other bank that I'm blanking on right
now uh signature in January of this year
and they created a very similar lending
vehicle people don't even know about
this but because of what I just
described where the FED funds rate was
escalated and they had all of these uh
you know short-term debt instruments
that were ultimately upside down they
created if they created a short-term
lending vehicle that was only on offer
to banks that had a it was never given
explicitly but based off of my uh
analysis it was any bank that had over
200 billion dollars in uh you know cash
on hand or deposits or money money under
management and so basically what that
means is that if you are banking with an
institution that's mid-size or massive
then your deposits nor worth of 250 000
are insured if you are Banking and
depositing with a bank that has less
than 200 billion so that's your mom and
pop Bank those are the banks that we
would probably us like us people would
like to like to do business with now our
deposits aren't insured with them so
what does that mean it it drives all of
us in this room to make the calculation
that it's actually more prudent for me
to bank with this scumbag Jamie Diamond
than it is to bank with this Mom and Pop
down the street that is that is a
terrible mismanagement mismanagement of
the economy and it is not accidental it
is ultimately the reason that Mercola
got debanked the reason that the entire
social credit score system is coming
they want us in the biggest banks
because the biggest banks are willing to
debank us if we don't go along right
it's easier to control if you've only
got five banks as opposed to three
thousand Banks what would you rather do
as a dumb government regulator who wants
to tell everyone to do thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and be become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time